garyvee just opened a restaurant in new
york where you have to own one of his
like access nfts or membership badges
nfts in order to eat at the restaurant
sick man yeah that's perfect for me
because i actually own like five
so oh you own five of them five
memberships so that you can why why five
um just in case i lose one just want to
make sure i'm backed up just a
redundancy
wallet in case i drop my wallet
digitally in the metaverse fly fish club
is the world's first member's only
private dining club where membership is
purchased on the blockchain as a
non-fungible token and owned by the
token holder to gain access to our
restaurant and various culinary cultural
and social experiences the space will
consist of a bustling cocktail lounge
upscale restaurant intimate amikase room
and outdoor space
i'm just gonna print out a picture of
like someone's butthole and be like this
is my nft
they told me to keep a hard copy
somewhere oh [ __ ] wait no that's my
butthole
oh sorry wrong wrong picture fold it up
put it in my big ass jacket and then
pull out like a file folder of all
printed images like these are all my
nfts
this is my portfolio make sure i you
know i keep them in one place
and then i just like put it on like the
[ __ ] host counter they're like oh you
can't i'm like just it should be a
second
shh
spreading and then the wind catches it
almost
yeah
i know that
no no no no no start flying down the
street wait no no that's my ape some
stall vendor snatches it up they're like
i'm rich push their [ __ ] stall over
punches a random dude in the face
yeah we should buy it now so that we can
really laugh at ourselves when it's
worth three dollars next year but we pay
a thousand now and the restaurant never
opens yeah no it does
but it's just like a subway yeah
sandwich
no not even it'll just be a it'll be a
pop-up only 369 is that how many they
made you can't a restaurant yes like the
restaurant's gonna be constantly empty
yeah the restaurant can't survive on 300
patrons [ __ ] out of here that is
hilarious man
the soho house isn't that expensive
isn't this so house like a grand and
that's for people that like socializing
yeah i kind of think that if you buy one
of these things you have to have enough
enough eath in your account that would
imply that you've been grinding on
crypto for the past couple years you
know what i'm saying you can't yeah
you're not going to drop 15 grand on an
nft like theoretical restaurant that's
opening next year unless you got way too
much which means that
you probably haven't been outside very
much
i think
in the past little while you know what
i'm saying yeah i love how we're finally
we're getting into this place where
there's like the real world and then the
fake world right like there's the
metaverse side of things and there's
like the real life side of things i
think it's gonna be really funny when
you know all of these attempts to mesh i
think the next iteration of this is
realizing that yeah none of these people
like to go outside so just do nfts for
things in vr i think then we'll fully
transition to you know all your nfts
being in your [ __ ] decentralian house
yeah the bridge bridging them over into
the real world just feels like we're
breaking some rule yeah it's gonna be
funny i was thinking of this like
imagine we live in a society where like
you do you're growing up in the
metaverse and then like they have to
bury you and send you away when you find
someone you love and you have kids in
the real world the real world is for
people with kids and then it's like
surrogate [ __ ] and then
everyone else is in the is in metaverse
and mark controls it all here we go
become a member
so these are mint prices for the
flagship
fly fish
4.25 eth i mean it's definitely like an
interesting concept isn't it like if it
ends up being really good and the food
is just
infamous then people will people will
buy these things on
the secondary market and then it'll just
become like the most exclusive
restaurant ever yeah but
can you imagine for that first year you
have to share it with garyvee fans yeah
that's so cool man so cool we should
definitely get these yeah we should
still open january 7th tomorrow dude how
much what was it four and a half that's
a lot 4.25 should we do it should we
just
get one on the company and then uh
that'd be do like cody and newell do
where we fly to new york when it opens
that'd be so funny cody noel do
garyvee private nft omakase restaurant
yeah
yeah i think it's
i think that's funny if we end up in the
garyvee restaurant and we like it
i'd be so i'll be so upset people like
so when are you gonna sell the
membership
yeah um yeah
we think it'd be funnier if we kept it
yeah it'd be funnier if we huddled it
you know the meme huddle it'd be way
funnier if we
kept eating here yeah be hilarious
actually the joke the joke is like a
long play like and then like imagine
like one day we like it that'd be funny
super funny as if dude
you